it's been a busy first week since Elon
Musk took control of Twitter on October
27th he appointed himself CEO make that
Chief twit or Twitter complaint hotline
operator there were plenty of complaints
when musk said people would have to
start paying eight dollars a month to
keep their blue check mark or to get one
AOC wasn't too happy musk's response to
the congresswoman pay up
the SpaceX and Tesla CEO didn't waste
any time getting down to business he
ousted Twitter's nine board of directors
to become the sole director though he
says being sole director is temporary he
also started to trim the fat and is
reportedly planning on eliminating
nearly half of Twitter's Workforce or 3
700 jobs according to Bloomberg these
two guys pretended to be laid off
employees and gave their names as Raul
ligma and Daniel Johnson to reporters
who fell for their prank but musk did
really start day one as chief of Twitter
by firing top Twitter Executives CEO
parag agrawal got the boot so did Chief
Financial Officer Ned Siegel and legal
Affairs and policy executive vijagadi
Gadi was reportedly instrumental in
permanently banning Donald Trump from
the platform for controversial tweets
related to the Capitol Hill riot in
January 2021. musk said Banning the
former U.S president was a morally bad
decision everyone is wondering whether
the former president will be back on
Twitter musk mused that if he had a
dollar for every time someone asked him
if Trump is coming back on this platform
Twitter would be minting money
before any big changes he says Twitter
will be forming a Content moderation
council with widely diverse viewpoints
no major content decisions or account
reinstatements will happen before that
Council convenes he said the process
would take at least a few more weeks
musk did buy the platform because he's a
self-described free speech absolutist
who believes Twitter should be the
digital Town Square but thinks it has
gone too far in squashing dissenting
opinions the final straw appears to have
been when Twitter suspended The Babylon
bee a Christian satire account that
named U.S assistant secretary for health
Dr Rachel Levine it's Man of the Year
many who are viewed as conservative feel
they've been unfairly targeted by
Twitter clinical psychologist Jordan
Peterson had his account suspended over
his post about transgender actor Elliot
page formerly Ellen Page but the
suspension will not be lifted unless I
delete the hateful tweet in question and
I would rather die than do that musk
replied to Peterson's daughter that
anyone suspended for minor and dubious
reasons will be freed from Twitter jail
Elon Musk won't only be freeing people
from Twitter jail just like his
Ambitions for SpaceX and Tesla he has
far bigger plans for Twitter in his view
Twitter is an accelerant to creating X
the everything app there's speculation
that he wants to replicate the success
of WeChat which has basically become the
everything app in China when YouTuber
Stephen Mark Ryan of solving the money
problem pointed out it's insane that
Twitter has not currently implemented a
YouTube clone musk responded with a wink
could we see creators monetizing videos
on Twitter
musk pulled people to ask if they wanted
to bring back Vine the short video
sharing app that Twitter shut down in
2016. he talked about it being a
possible competitor for tick tock all
these plans rely on good engineering
musk reportedly sent in his trusted
Tesla Engineers to inspect Twitter's
code to assess the company's needs
they'll have to tackle the problem of
fake and spam accounts in fact musk
tried to get out of buying Twitter
believing it wasn't worth the 44 billion
he offered to take it private due to the
number of spam Bots musk believes the
way to defeat the spambots while also
making money for Twitter is to start
charging you for this blue check mark
this is arguably his most controversial
move during week one the blue
verification badge has become a status
symbol granted to journalists
celebrities politicians some of whom
were Furious when they heard they'd have
to pay 19.99 a month to keep their Blue
Tick as reported by the Verge musk
replied to an unhappy Stephen King that
Twitter needs to pay the bills somehow
and wondered if the horror author might
be willing to dish out eight dollars
instead he called the current system for
who has and doesn't have the Blue Tick
BS in that charging eight dollars a
month for anyone who wants it would mean
more power to the people this would be
part of the Twitter blue Subscription
Service which comes with other benefits
although musk has long boasted that
Tesla does not pay for advertising
advertising has been crucial to
Twitter's survival General Motors
temporarily pulled ads from Twitter
following the Takeover musk tried to
reassure advertisers that Twitter would
be a respected advertising platform in
an open letter he stressed that he
doesn't want Twitter to become a
free-for-all hellscape where anything
can be said with no consequences he also
said he bought Twitter to help Humanity
whom I love
will people love the new Twitter
users have been noticing some changes
when the White House boasted seniors are
getting the biggest Social Security
increase in a decade thanks to President
Biden context Checkers pointed out it's
because inflation has been the highest
in decades the White House then deleted
the Tweet musk can only hope that
Twitter soars to new heights like his
rocket company SpaceX though some have
vowed to leave
however you feel let that sink in that a
new boss is in town
Twitter is now a private company and
will no longer be listed on the New York
Stock Exchange however millions of
investors have already dropped their
shares in the last few months as it got
too volatile and their caution is well
founded the classic 60 40 portfolio of
stocks and bonds the go-to investing
method for decades has lost around 34
percent this year as a result Goldman
Sachs says portfolios need to be
rebalanced to avoid further losses they
highlight the importance of investing in
real assets that have historically
outperformed in volatile conditions
assets like Fine Art and it's why
Masterworks is seeing increased demand
this year Masterworks lets you invest in
multi-million dollar paintings from
Legends like Picasso you can buy shares
in these paintings without owning
Millions yourself
contemporary art has outpaced the S P
500 by 131 percent for the last 26 years
even during the bull market of the last
decade in October Masterworks sold this
painting by George condo for a 21.5 net
return in fact six of Masterworks 7
sales have brought in over 20 net
returns Masterworks has a wait list to
join their 550 000 Plus members but you
can skip the wait list by clicking the
custom link in the description that's
masterworks.art newsthink
masterworks.art newsthink to get started
investing in Fine Art thanks for
watching for news think I'm Cindy Palm